uh our final speaker of the day is
becoming a regular
at hillsdale college events uh donald
rumsfeld served as the 13th and the 21st
united states secretary of defense
he currently chairs the non-profit
rumsfeld foundation along with his wife
joyce
a graduate of princeton university and a
formal naval aviator
his list of accomplishments is long and
impressive
allow me to mention just a few he was
elected to the u.s house of
representatives at the age of 30
and was reelected three consecutive
times
he held high-level positions in the
administrations of four
u.s presidents and he has been chief
executive officer of two
fortune 500 companies his many honors
and awards include all navy
wrestling champion which i think was
probably excellent preparation for
dealing with the white house
press corps especially during during the
invasions of iraq
in afghanistan he's also the recipient
of the distinguished
eagle scout award and the nation's
highest civilian award the presidential
medal of freedom he's an author
he wrote a best-selling memoir known and
unknown and he recently wrote a second
best-selling book
rumsfeld's rules leadership lessons in
business politics war and life
he has graciously agreed to sign copies
of this book
rumsfeld's rules immediately following
his talk today the signing will take
place in plaza ballroom b which is right
next door
to this room finally i would be remiss
if i neglected to mention that mr
rumsfeld and his wife joyce who have
three children
seven grandchildren and a great
granddaughter
were married in 1954 which means they
are celebrating 60 years
of marriage this year and i think that's
worth congratulating them on
he will be speaking today on the topic
leadership lessons in business politics
war and life please welcome former
united states secretary of defense
the honorable donald rumsfeld
my goodness greetings
thank you
well i uh i just had a chance to hear
some of mr shapiro's comments
and it called to mind an event i
attended
when i was old enough to know better
and the speaker before me
finished his remarks by showing the
video
of the u.s russia hockey match
when the when the americans beat them
and walking in here after that very
interesting
clever individual is a bit like that i
wow does he say it
well thank you very much timothy and and
larry yarn and
members of the faculty the
administration supporters of
hillsdale good for you
what you do is worth while it's
important
our country needs the products of this
fine institution
i uh i've
i guess i left government but for the
third or fourth time
some years back and as tim said i
have a foundation where we do support
for military charities
microfinance around the world
graduate fellows people who don't have
the resources to
go to college and get a master's and a
phd
and central asian fellows
the excuse me the
memoir i wrote known and unknown
came the title came from a serious
process
where i used herman khan's technique
where he takes a piece of paper draws a
line across it he used to do this he's
long gone
but was an interesting friend of mine
and he'd put a whole lot of ideas
about something he was working on so i
decided the title of the book i'd start
getting everyone's ideas for titles and
i'd take
one and roll it around in my head a bit
and then i'd put it below the line
and then i'd look at the below never
throw them out
and then i'd look at one below the line
and say you know that's not bad i'll put
it back above the line
well finally i came up with known and
unknown
i was worried it was a little orwellian
it came from a press conference i had in
the pentagon where
i was trying to describe the problem of
intelligence
and i said that there are known knowns
the things we know we know there are
known unknowns
the things we know we don't know
but there are also unknown unknowns
the things that we don't know we don't
know
and they're the ones that get you
the the last competitor
to known and unknown was
an old wyoming saying that goes
like this dogs don't bark at
parked cars
now i've been barked at a few times in
my life
and my response to that is they do do
something to park
cars
well but my wife said that's not it's a
not elegant you don't want to use that
one
the um the second book i wrote was
rumsfeld's rules and i've been asked to
talk a bit about it which i'm happy to
do
i'm told that at 81 years old i'm
getting a little gearless so i'll have
to be careful and i hope someone gives
me the hook after 10 or 15 minutes so i
can
save time to respond to questions
but what rumsfeld's rules were
first of all they're not all rules uh
second they're certainly not rumsfelds
they're
people a lot smarter than i am but one
day i was
called back from nato where i was
ambassador and
gerald ford had suddenly become
president the only man in history who
had not run for president and had not
run for vice president
and was serving in the oval office as
the president of the united
states a a person
he's i guess he was the only president i
worked at it was a personal friend we'd
served in congress together
and i'd help manage his campaign for
minority leader back in 1964.
wonderful human being a very honorable
man
and of course the reservoir of trust had
been drained and
he helped refill it just because of his
integrity and his decency and his
his talent as a legislator but he was
not an executive
and i would he asked me to be chair as
transition then he asked me to be chief
of staff of the white house and
i didn't want to but i've been there for
four years before that and
but i finally agreed and
one day i was with him and and i made
some comment
uh i don't know what it was i might have
said mr president
if you're working off your inbox you're
working off the priorities of others
and the goal is to have them working off
your outbox
or i might have said what you measure
improves
in the military they put it differently
they say you get what you inspect
not what you expect and he asked me and
he said well what's that all about and i
said well i s
my mom was a school teacher and when i'd
asked her what a word meant she'd say
well
write it down look it up
use it so i started writing down words
as a youngster and
and i still do talk about a dutiful son
and i started keeping track of concepts
or thoughts that i thought were of
particular interest
well the president asked me to get them
typed up they were all in a file
in cards and notes and i did and he
wanted him passed out
to the senior staff at the white house
because he literally had
climbed into a an airplane going 500
miles an hour and he didn't even know
the crew
he'd only been vice president 15 minutes
little longer
but it was it was a terribly difficult
time for the country
and so i i sent those around to the
senior staff as he requested
and i must say that the uh
it's now been close to 40 years i think
that was 1974 there'd been something
like 40 years that those things have
been
circular circulating around basically in
mimeograph form
i uh i
decided after i wrote my memoir that i
kind of enjoyed writing a book and
and decided to put them together into a
book
the uh the book is is
um is kind of eclectic it has
chapters on negotiating
on wrestling on the military on business
uh various on capitalism i got so
disturbed about the last campaign and
the
quality of the discussion on capitalism
that i decided to put in a chapter on
that
as i walked around the pentagon or or
businesses that i was involved
in over the years i'd see strategy on
door after door
and the more i talked to people the more
it became very clear to me that everyone
had a slightly different idea of what
strategy was
and and people didn't really appreciate
how hard strategy is it's hard for a lot
of reasons but the first reason is
you don't have a strategy unless you
know where you want to go
so you have to decide these are your
goals
and once you do that someone's not going
to like those goals
and they're going to disagree with you
whether you're in business or in
government
or in a family and they're going to say
well that's not
the goal we ought to have so it's risky
to have a strategy because you have to
begin with a goal
then you have to decide what are the
conditions circumstances
in which you're going to be pursuing
that goal and what course of action
i remember when i was at in the
pharmaceutical business i decided to
take a
good portion of the data and make it
public and put it in the quarterly and
annual reports
so the shareholders could look and see
what i thought was important what we
were trying to
improve because that's what we were
measuring
and then taking the risk that you fall
short and the numbers won't get better
they'll get worse
so strategy is not easy and and i
thought
i'd do a chapter on that which i did
the um
the ideas that are in the book are
things that
i noticed this is a leadership
conference and i've had the privilege of
attending
one or two others of these conferences
and i i was
looking at the schedule you have and was
most impressed
one of the rules in the book i learned
as a
young navy pilot when i in the flight
manual of an
old snj all the planes i flew are now
hanging from the ceilings
of museums and uh
but but there was it used to be a little
training plane called
an snj and what what
it said in the manual was if you're lost
climb conserve and confess
not bad there's some folks in washington
who could
learn from learn from that but what it
meant was you get some altitude so you
can
if if you need to you can find a field
and
and get down uh so you get you climb
conserve is you put your fuel back
low so you have the maximum amount of
time to
cruise and figure out what you might be
doing and then confess
get on the radio and say i am lost
and that's hard but it's not bad advice
for
for all of us from time to time to uh
get to that point where you're willing
to say that
and and certainly it's a it's a thought
with respect to leadership
the first thing i'd say about leadership
is the world is really run
by people who show up
uh people say to me all this that and
the other thing and
and we all recognize how important
governance is
i'm from illinois and uh when i hear
people talk about
corruption in other countries i think
that it
in my adult life in
i think we've had four go to the slammer
governors
and um so it is
it is important that we that we show up
and if people say well what what are we
going to do and wring our hands and
isn't everything horrible
the place to solve the problem is by
looking in the mirror
because it is each of us individuals
human beings who have this amazing
opportunity to help guide
and direct the course of our of our
government of our country
and that that creates the environment
within which we all function
and so that that thought
that the world is run by those who show
up
is an interesting one another another
thought i was with a fellow the other
day on a panel at the truman library
and he what did i say that made you
leave like
is that your knapsack you're taking or
the uh the fella i was with he said you
know if you're a leader
and you're walking down the road and no
one's following you
you're not a leader you're just out
taking a walk
and the other thought in there of course
on this subject is that
if you don't know where you're going any
road will get you there
when i got married my wife's father said
to me don if you're coasting
you're going downhill
which is uh is true one night i was in
tel aviv with shimon peres having dinner
at a chinese restaurant with my
youngest youngest daughter and the three
of us were sitting there eating chinese
food in in this
he had been minister of defense when i
was secretary of defense back in the 70s
and we were talking about the middle
east and what was going on
and he said very simply don
if a problem has no solution
it's not a problem it's a fact
not to be solved but to be coped with
over time
which i think has some validity it's uh
it's it's worth thinking about bill
bennett who's a friend one day said to
me you know if you really want to know
what's going on
you give it the gate test i said well
what's the gate test
he said will you pick up the gate and
see which way things are moving
and if you think about that it's true of
money
money's a coward money leaves a place
that's inhospitable
and finds a place that's marginally more
hospitable
human beings leave places that are in
less hospitable and move to places that
are more hospitable
and it doesn't take a genius to to to
do that to look at the flow look at the
the direction
things are moving i remember maryland
recently passed a millionaires tax
and they were receiving so much revenue
for x number of millionaires
they passed the tax and the revenue
didn't go up the revenue went down why
because the millionaires left
and they were surprised
how can you be surprised
my favorite photograph is a satellite
photo of the korean peninsula
and i've got a picture of it in my book
and it it tells it all
i mean there's the this little peninsula
with a demilitarized zone across the
middle
the same people in the north and the
south the same resources in the north
and south
the same culture the same language in
the north and the south
the same neighbors and in the south
since the korean war they have become
the 13th
biggest economy on the face of the earth
and in the north they're starving the
satellite
photo shows at night electricity
throughout
south korea and along the coast
and in the north it's pitch black except
for a pin
prick of light in the capital city of
pyngyang
that tells us that
and the only difference really is that
in the south they have a free
political system and a free economic
system
in the north they have a dictatorship
and what's a dictator do he gets up
every morning
and tries to figure out how he's going
to perpetuate himself in office
that's that's his job winston churchill
put it well he said a dictator rides a
tiger
and he's afraid to get off
and and it's it's true and the only way
to stay
in power as a dictator is to repress
and that's what's happening in that part
of the world and people want to flee
if you give it the gate test they're
constantly trying to get out of that
country
and and escape the um
one other thought on leadership is you
know it is perfectly possible
to proceed perfectly logically from an
inaccurate premise to an inaccurate
conclusion
and it happens a lot i
i think also it's it's important to
remember that
one should be aware of ideas that
are bold innovative and new
it is perfectly possible to have an idea
that is bold
innovative new and stupid
mrs chan mrs thatcher once said that the
only trouble with socialism
is that pretty soon you run out of other
people's money
which of course has a lot of truth
a a thought that
i think it was toynbee said that
civilizations
die from suicide not murder
that is to say that that human beings in
a civilization have that responsibility
themselves to either see that it
flourishes
and grows or that bad decisions are made
bad governance exists and it dies
of its own in effect
suicide well of course one of my last
rules is
is is
if you have rules never have more than
10.
i think in the book there's something
like 283.
so the actually the final rule is that
that all generalizations are wrong
including this one
now what i thought i'd do is stop i'm
having trouble seeing
folks i don't know how you're going to
handle the questions and answers i know
how i'll handle the answers
i'll answer the questions i know the
answer to and i'll respond to the others
but i can't see out there to see a hand
how do we do this
um thank you mr rumsfeld very much
uh we have a couple of students with
microphones uh they'll
the students will find the questions if
you raise your hand and keep it up we'll
come to you
and ask away good
thank you the questions need not be on
my book
although that would be nice i i want to
say one other thing about my first book
the memoir known and unknown all the
proceeds go to military charities so
don't be shy don't be shy
you you can you can get out your
christmas card list and send it to all
your friends
and i can say that without any
embarrassment
yes first of all very grateful that
you're here
um i do have one grateful prideful thing
to say that i have in common with you my
grandparents and my parents and my
brother and sister and i are all alma
matters of new trier
is that right high school yeah and uh
here's to our team they're the green and
the great
my father was always uh yeah they were
called the indians but they have we're
not allowed to do that
yeah right yeah my father whenever we
would go visit my mother at
uh winneconne community church he said
david over there
are the parents of a great man and so we
would always say hello to your parents
as well well my goodness thank you buddy
my sister still goes there yeah well i'd
probably meet her once in a while there
the tea party which which started out as
a tax revolt has i think
uh become to many people
uh synonymous before you go on
you know one time i was at the grand ole
opry in nashville
and dolly parton and i were on the stage
and i walked up and she
said well i'd like to have you say a few
words to the audience
and she had the mic
and so i reached for the mic and an old
pro like that
she held onto the mic
and i ended up for the first phrase
sounding like you sound like the mic
isn't near your face
it's too far away all right so i finally
wrestled it away from dolly parton
and my advice to you is do the same
[Applause]
oh megan i'd love to wrestle you but not
right now
[Applause]
when you said we had something in common
i thought you
i thought you were going to say you were
an all-navy wrestling champion oh god
so i i what i wanted to ask you is this
the tea party which you know started out
as
obviously a tax revolt um has become
synonymous i think in
it started out as what a tax revolt oh a
tax revolt you know tax enough already
um but it has become synonymous with
what i think
many people certainly not everybody here
but many people consider
to be the uh non-compromising
bible thumping far right um
i think that i guess i know there's
somebody who disagree with that
but i think that's what the president
said something like they like their guns
and their bibles
well one what's happening of late is i
think we can see a revisionist
republican party that is proposing
um candidates that are
non-tea partyists more moderate my
question to you is
number one is this uh a positive path
strategy for the republicans to come
back into
government and also can we be moderate
and still be faithful to conservative
values
well that is a a tough question and for
someone who's
really been out of power politics for a
good many years
i would hearken back to a couple of
thoughts
um when i was living in brussels as
ambassador to nato i watched these
countries that had multi-party systems
and they were weak the any small
party could pull them down and change
the government so
one time when i was there i think the
netherlands
had no government for six months
because the it pulled apart so i believe
in a two-party system
and i also believe in the energy and the
vitality that the tea party people have
brought
to the country i think
[Applause]
it was ronald reagan who said he
believed in the big tent
and and we have to believe in a big tent
if you
believe in a two-party system and if you
want to govern what you have to do is
see that that party becomes
as much like you would want it to be as
is humanly possible given the fact what
do we have 312 or 15 million people in
this country
uh we're all going to have somewhat
different views
uh but but i think it was bill buckley
said
who am i for i am for the most
conservative
person who can get elected and
and and that it seems to me
is is not an unreasonable position
uh we're not gonna always prevail
uh what our particular views might be
but by golly uh we we are responsible
for guiding and directing the course of
this country
and and the only way that can happen is
if we get out of our chairs
understand how enormously important
what's happening is
and participate and and out of that
process
and and i give enormous credit to the
tea party folks
a lot of whom are close friends of mine
for what they have brought by way of
energy and
and vitality and and uh thoughtfulness
uh to the uh to the public dialogue
on on important issues does that answer
your question
you know i think the chances are of the
tea party
i think there's so negativity so much
negativity towards
the the rabid right and i i say that
cautiously but
i wonder are we going to be able to get
elected
and if we can't get elected
well if you can't get elected you can't
govern and if you can't govern somebody
else is going to govern
and the people we're going to be
governing are going to be people without
our values without our interests
and in too many instances governing in a
way that in my view would not be in the
best interests of the country so
so what we have to do is recognize that
that sure we can
we can uh stick with our values it's
important that we do
certainly ronald reagan did
and i think that
the one thing i will say is that
everything we say or do
is trumpeted to the country
through the mainstream media and it
comes out
in a way that is often not in favor of
the kind of
ideas that i have or the values that i
i prefer and and recommend and urge
and that ought not to call us
indeed it ought to energize us it ought
to cause us to
to to stand up and say by golly
they can say what they want about it
they can twist it
uh but but it isn't going to slow me
down
i'm a dogs don't bark at park cars
[Applause]
secretary rumsfeld i'm looking at a
letter
dated april 15 14 to our beloved irs
over your signature and if i may quote
from it i assume it's accurate
i hope that at some point in my lifetime
and i'm now in my 80s
so there are not many years left the us
government will simplify the u.s tax
code
so that those citizens who sincerely
want to pay
what they should are able to do it right
and know that they have done it right so
my question is
he left out the first part of my letter
well it's a long letter
every do i'll read it all yeah but it's
a good one
do you remain hopeful every year i write
the irs and say here are my taxes
i don't have the vagus idea if they're
accurate
i went to college i hire an accountant i
want them to be accurate
but the thing is so complicated i can't
promise you that they're out if you have
any questions give me a call
[Applause]
now what do i think will the tax code
get simplified
certainly not with this government
but it has to be it is absolutely
irresponsible for a country like ours
to have a tax code that is so big so
thick so complex
that people cannot know whether or not
what they're doing
is correct i put a ps and said my wife
also signed this she all
she also went to college and she also
doesn't have the vagus idea but
if it's accurate but but we have to do
it we have
we have no excuse as responsible
citizens to not simplify it and go to
some kind of a flat tax
question yes mr rumsfeld right here
yes it's it's an honor to be in uh
in the presence of such a great patriot
and thank you for your service thank you
very much
um it's a it's been a privilege to serve
believe me
one of my fondest memories of you is i
think during the beginning of the ira
uh the afghanistan war during the pre
pentagon press briefings and i think it
could have been pay-per-view because it
was such a delight for me to see
you handle with such deafness
intelligence and grace
the weenies of the pentagon press course
so i just wanted to tell you i enjoyed
it thoroughly
thank you
i wish my wife joyce were here to hear
that
i'd get home at night and she'd say how
does all that stuff come out of your
mouth
sir would you uh speak
about the uh break uh the disarming
the break the diminishing of our armed
forces
yes sir but what's happened is
throughout america's history
we have after world war one we built up
during the war and then we pared back
dramatically and became
really truly a third-rate power military
power
in world war ii we built up at the end
of the war we pulled down
dramatically at the korean war we had to
build up
and and uh then at the end of that we
pulled down
it's happened every single time when i
got out of the navy and went to
washington to work on capitol hill it
was 1957.
eisenhower was president in eisenhower's
presidency we were spending 10 percent
of gross national product on defense
same thing was basically true in the
kennedy and johnson
all that period republicans democrats
about 10 percent of gdp today we're
spending less than four percent
of gdp and our allies are spending less
than two percent
in nato and western europe now
i think it was sun tzu who said the the
best war is the one that doesn't have to
be fought
what for most of my adult life
the united states has been a
factor in the world it's been
contributed to the rib cage
not as policemen of the world we can't
do that we don't
have the ability to nation build but but
we've been a factor
and an important factor
the signal that's gone out in recent
years
is that first of all we're not capable
or don't care
about managing our economy in a
responsible way
and therefore we are racking up debts
and deficits that tell
the world that we're going to be less as
a nation
in the next two decades than we've been
in the earlier period
and that's a dangerous single then they
see the sequestration of the defense
department
budget and and the reductions that are
taking place
in the in the budgets and they say well
the united states is just simply
withdrawing
why else if you're in decline why else
would
vice president biden have to stand up
and say we're not in decline
he had to say that because we are and
we're we're not behaving as a
as a factor in the world now what does
that do nature abhor is a vacuum
we're creating a leadership vacuum
across the globe
which means that that vacuum is going to
be filled by people
who have totally different values and
don't have our interests
and will be doing and deciding to do
things that they otherwise
wouldn't even think of doing no one here
thought
gee maybe i'll fly over from my hotel to
this hotel
today because you can't fly any country
across the globe if it's if it's
some country that has totally different
views from art
they are encouraged to do things that
they otherwise wouldn't think of doing
because they see weakness friends and
allies when we'd go to them
i mean think of when president obama
went to a friends and allies
about syria i don't know 20 30
000 people had been killed by that time
and and he
tried to put together a coalition and no
one would follow him
he he didn't ever actually
articulate a mission
now i think it's something like 140 000
they announced today
have been killed in syria and and
um i guess
that my worry
is that the countries of the world are
shifting their focus
and they're i mean clearly mr putin
believes he can do
pretty much what he wants to do and so
he gets up in the morning and
and decides what he wants to do when
he's interested in kind of reasserting
russian interest in authorities over the
former soviet republics and
uh what they call the near abroad and
you find
him putting pressure on him in one day i
mean if you were in central asia
or the old warsaw block countries that
aren't in nato
you'd have to worry what's next
i mean that churchill i think said the
trouble with
it it's like feeding an alligator hoping
it eats you last
you you can you can only do so many
things
and you've created an impression you've
created a
a an understanding in the world
that that you have decided to withdraw
and to pull back and to not have the
financial wherewithal
and to not have the military well
wherewithal to provide the kind of
deterrent
and dissuasion because weakness is
provocative
weakness invites people into doing
things they wouldn't even think of doing
otherwise
so as you may have surmised from my
response i have a minimum of high regard
for what's taking place
question secretary runsfield
secretary ramsey yes sir again thank you
very very much for your service we
appreciate that
thank you uh i'm wondering with all the
experience you've had
all the people you've been around all
the leaders and
want to be leaders what characteristics
do you
see that are needed in the secretaries
and the senators
in the congressman on our side of the
argument
that are lacking today
do i make myself clear or am i
yeah but
well i'm plucky but i'm not stupid no no
no
you want me to issue a blanket
indictment
no no no i just uh i was just wondering
if there are certain things
i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm
happy to happy to respond
first first we'll take the members of
the congress
they are each elected separately
in a different constituency they
raise their own money they're not
beholden to the party
or the leadership of the party i think
boehner has got one of the toughest jobs
in the world
and and mitch mcconnell trying to keep
everyone
focused and going in generally the right
direction
because they don't have to do that
they're they're independent of that
leadership
and uh now what does that mean well take
a committee hearing
uh any hearing hearing on the irs or the
hearing in benghazi
what you see is a group of individuals
who know that they are going to run for
re-election
they know they have to raise money to
win re-election
they know to raise to raise money you
have to be
people have to know who you are how do
they know who you are
through television so what do you do you
say something on television in a
committee hearing
now the only way you can actually manage
a hearing with a cabinet officer sitting
down there
and and you're running a hearing the way
to do it is to have one or two or three
people ask all the questions
instead of having people pop in and pop
out and say i'm sorry i have to leave
and i just came in from another
committee meeting
and then read a question that their
staff prepared
you have to be willing to to have person
given enough time
that they can ask a question of the
witness they can listen to the answer
listening is a very gracious art
and and then ask a question off that
question
whereas if each person's allocated three
minutes
all the way around the room it never
happens
so i think the thing that has to be done
now take this select committee
that's just been appointed in the
congress they're going to have to get
a chief counsel and they're going to
have to
reduce dramatically the amount of time
that each member has
and focus so that you can actually
pursue a line of questioning
that can get to the bottom of something
and you can't do it if everyone's got
free play
with the with respect to the executive
branch
i was having lunch one time with bibi
netanyahu and
and he said we got talking about
coalitions and
we've seen just in the last two decades
all kinds of coalitions
major organizations are coalitions the
un's a coalition nato is a coalition
but the thing to remember is
that the mission has to determine the
coalition
the coalition can't determine the
mission if if the coalition comes
together
for reasons other than the purpose that
is at hand
they're not going to agree to it i mean
the u.n
what can it do it can give speeches
but it's so big and and there are so
many different perspectives and views
in there and there's so many countries
that have vetoes that the idea that that
quote
coalition can deal with problems like
piracy or
the proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction or some of the major issues
that the world faces
uh it's it's very clear that they are
they are not able to
so what has to be done is a leader has
to provide clarity of vision
articulate a specific mission and then
go out and find
countries that are willing to support
that mission
the point being that the mission has to
determine the coalition
seems to me if you're talking about the
executive branch what we have to do is
or political leaders outside of congress
they have to decide directionally
what's important what needs to be done
provide sufficient clarity of vision and
then
recruit people to support that mission
and and recognize that only if they do
that
uh are we likely to to move the ball
down the field
and and clearly to the extent that
people are working at cross purposes or
don't agree
with the coalition's mission or
end up feeling that they didn't have a
voice in that mission they didn't sign
up to do that if you will
i i was struck during the bush
administration
that he was constantly accused of being
a unilateralist
he put together a coalition of over 90
countries
to support the global war on terror and
cooperate
through their fbi's cooperate with
respect to
tracking uh financial transactions
uh then there were probably 30 some odd
that were
in the coalition uh to deal with
afghanistan
30 countries not the u.n not nato
but a a clear purpose
and 30-plus countries that got involved
eventually nato did come in and get
involved
same thing with iraq 25 or 30 countries
there came together
i think 52 countries came together with
respect to the
proliferation security initiative and
when we were putting that together
i would go around to a country and say
look
here's where we're going here's what we
want to do
we want your help we'll take your help
on
any basis you want if your political
situation is such that you can't do it
publicly
fair enough don't do it publicly
if your situation is that you can help
with this part of it but not that part
of it
fine we'll take that and and fashion
a a a coalition of people
that are generally moving in a certain
direction
and accept the fact that they're all
different than we are they have
different histories different cultures
different languages
different neighbors different political
circumstances
and don't expect them all to be like we
are i mean we're not like we were
this country had slaves into the 1800s
women didn't vote into the 1900s
we're evolving they're evolving and the
idea that they should all be exactly
like
us or agree with us on things in every
case i think is is un
terribly unrealistic question
did that answer that question
uh mr rumsfeld yes um 2016 is coming up
uh can we the republican party
beat hillary in 2016
and if so what kind of candidate
do we need
well i can't imagine first of all let me
say that i'm
i'm not big on dynasties
with over 300 million people we ought to
have more than two or three families
that can produce people who can lead in
this country
second uh i i think she was a rather
poor secretary of state
so if two legs of her stool won his
dynasty and the other's the department
of state
she'd have to have a wonderful third leg
of that stool
i can't imagine really cannot imagine
the country electing her
um now
what what what i think i've already
answered the other part of the question
is what does the republican party need
they they need somebody who is a leader
somebody who's capable of
deciding which way to go and then having
the skill sets to go out
and create a coalition of people who
want to go in that direction
and being persuasive and finding ways to
get each of you
each of us out of our chairs
understanding how important
this next election is i mean what the
damage that can be done in eight years
is enormous
you add four more and and it's a quite
different world
and and i mean the the people that are
getting sprinkled throughout the
executive branch are people who
are not going to get up in the morning
and walk the same direction
you may be or i may be so i
i think it's what someone said to me
well who are you for and i said i want
to watch him run around the track
i want to want to see him show their
stuff i want to see him under attack and
see how they respond
i want him to deal with tough issues and
and find a way to to do it
effectively and and become that kind
of a leader that will energize the
people who
generally have the kinds of views that i
have and i'm willing to invest the time
and effort
to do that and and and and
watch them go and help them go and and
then
uh land on one of them and break my neck
trying to get him
him or her elected question
between russia and china which one do
you think is our greater
foreign rival
you know we look at those two countries
um
take russia russia has
a lot of nuclear weapons
it also has a not an impressive
military they're conscripts
most of them don't want to be there
they're not well educated
they're not well disciplined
except for energy the russian economy is
modest
many countries around the world don't
like russians
and because of their
pressures that it puts on them they can
be responsive to that pressure
and they will be responsive to that
pressure
but um but that that they don't like
them
and they don't want to receive that
pressure let me put it that way
alcoholism is a serious problem they've
got a brain out train
i think it's the first modern
industrialized country where the
life expectancy of males has actually
declined
[Music]
are they well led yes there's no
question but that
putin is punching way above his weight
class
and we're punching well below
um take china
china's got problems the one baby
problem was
a big mistake they've got i don't know
40 50 60 million men with no women
they've got a disparity of wealth from
the coast to the inner part of their
country
they're they've still got all these
large uh government
communist uh corporations that are going
to have to be broken up at some point
and the people let go
and when the people are let go they're
going to have to put security people in
there
they've got a problem because they have
a
want to grow their economy at a good
clip
and to do that you're going to have to
allow a lot of foreigners in your
country
and a lot of ipads and telephones
cell phones and and a freer
bit of energy and they have a communist
dictatorship
which does not benefit from computers
and people
have the ability to organize and so
forth so there's going to be attention
and and if they want to grow the way
they've been growing they're going to
have to give up something
and have some things that are not
compatible
to their political dictatorship
communist dictatorship so they each of
those
and it has on the plus side uh it has
uh central leadership i mean the
mischief they're making in the south
china sea is
is an enormous problem right now it's
it's affecting all of our friends and
allies there
south korea japan singapore australia
the philippines vietnam vietnam is
it is think i mean think of the
countries that have border problems with
china
vietnam does india does other countries
around the periphery of china constantly
feel the pressure
so which is the major problem
if if we manage our affairs well
we are a wealthy country we have the
ability to do
not to do everything but to do
everything that's necessary
inappropriate
and and to create a
a rib cage in the world that deters and
dissuades either one or both of those
countries
from engaging in excessive mischief
and harm to our values and our friends
and our allies
i think that we
we have to expect that each will be
attempting to expand
each will be attempting to exert
influence
and to the extent we've adopted a policy
of
of mismanaging our economy
reducing our defense investments
behaving in a way that discourages our
friends and allies
and creating the kind of weakness that
is sufficiently provocative that it
encourages the leadership in in russia
and um and and the people's republic of
china
we're going to lose and and i as between
the two
china clearly is is bigger and and
has a much more rapidly growing economy
and is double-digit investing in their
defense
it also has those problems i've
described i think that
it it is going to depend basically on us
how we manage our affairs and i think
that
each of those two countries and the
problems they present to their neighbors
and the world are manageable problems if
we manage ourselves in a responsible way
and pull up our socks and act like a
great country
[Applause]
this will be our last question uh mr
rumsfeld personal question
uh i know i'd be pleased if i could be
among the encountered among the handful
of bogeymen for the
from the left for the left uh from your
from your standpoint um i'm guessing
that
uh when they say it's uh bush's fault
there's cheney's fault it's nicaragua's
fault
you don't cry yourself to sleep at night
but how do you how do you approach that
do you just let that slough
off are you are you happy to be to be a
target for the left thank you
you know if you act like a welcome mat
people wipe their feet on you
and i never really learned to roll over
and play dead dog
i uh i i get up every morning
and and if i feel
that what the things i believe in are
basically right
even though i know some people are going
to disagree with them i'm perfectly
willing to
go out and say what i believe and to the
extent someone disagrees
at least they're thinking and and and
they're wrong
uh
[Applause]
i'm getting the hook i can feel a
presence on my left
so i'm i'm i'm not gonna go home wring
my hands and cry myself to sleep
you